our next guest is Steven hill and he has
a book out called raw deal how the uber
economy and runaway capitalism are
screwing American workers Steven hill
joining us good morning thank you pager
my pleasure so let's start with this
idea of an uber economy what do you mean
by that and talk about the worker
involved sure well so what as we've seen
the economy evolve in the post-world War
two ERA we've seen companies changing a
lot so now there's a sort of new type of
company where are they're called sharing
economy gig economy companies and what
they do is they connect a buyer of a
good or service with a seller of a good
service without any middle person no
store or anything so you can go on a
website like Etsy and buy you know maybe
something that's been knit by a person
or a jewelry that's been made by a
custom-made person or you can get a taxi
service from uber or lyft or you can go
on an air B&B and get a hotel
essentially and so there's no middle
person these companies are saying we're
not a hotel we're not a taxi company
we're just a technology company
providing a brokerage in a sense for
connecting buyer and seller so this is
what the the gig economy is about the
the challenge that's coming in is is
that the economy was the law is the
labor laws as such have what have you
we're not set up for these sorts of
workers and so these sorts of workers
are finding challenges for example these
companies don't provide any kind of
health care safety net they don't give
you any kind of job security the wages
are actually quite low so in the
aftermath of the 2008-2009 crisis with a
lot of the good jobs that we had in this
economy you know that had to healthcare
and had decent pay and job security they
went away and what they were replaced
with were you know for example a fifth
of the new jobs were temp jobs and about
half the new jobs created barely paid
more than minimum wage so we took the
good jobs replaced them with a lot of
crummy jobs and a lot of these crummy
jobs are being filled by this gig
economy so you would call an uber driver
a crummy job because the way they would
sell it is look you can get your own
destiny work your own hours make as much
as you want and provide maximum
flexibility to them right well if it's
working for you as a driver then by all
means do it it's better
sitting home and having no way to make
money at all but increasingly what we're
seeing with these drivers of you asking
you know bla people say well I asked my
youtuber driver and he says he likes it
just fine
you know I said ask him how long he's
been driving because the clear patterns
that the longer you've been driving for
uber the less you like it in fact ubers
own numbers show that about half of
their drivers last year on that platform
and then they move on because you get
used to you know uber cuts pay of the
wait the wages of the drivers on a
fairly regular basis you can be cut off
the platform at any time because you
know a whole number of things that you
do that aren't really egregious in any
way just like your acceptance rate of
people who ping you for a ride you say
no I don't want to do that right if your
acceptance rate is too low uber will cut
you off so there's there's a lot of
things that we're learning about how
this new economy works then I think you
know if we regulate these companies the
right way we can make these jobs into
decent enough jobs but these are never
going to be the types of jobs that you
can revive the US economy on it's just
not gonna happen on the cover of your
book you mentioned uber you meant
there's another company Airbnb and then
another company TaskRabbit are these
rich companies some of them are richer
than others but keep in mind these are
all startups venture capital funded and
so we don't really know how successful
they are it's all their own numbers I
mean I sometimes say trusting uber
because they release all these numbers
about how their drivers are doing and
sort of like trusting the tobacco
companies to do their own studies we
really need to have our own independent
way to measure how good are these jobs
and the people that are measuring them
independently are finding you know for
example an uber driver at one time the
CEO of uber Travis County was saying
these are my drivers full-time or making
$100,000 a year well then some
journalists without an app rode with
some uber drivers said let me see your
pay stubs and discovered they're not
making really any more than taxi drivers
and a lot of them because you have to
pay for your own expenses when you're
driving your own car you know gasoline
and insurance and the wear and tear in
your car they're making some of the
drivers are saying they're making less
than minimum wage so this is you know
this is if somebody drives are doing
better than others you talk about these
three companies but is this a trend as
in full time workers being laid off by
big companies becoming independent
contractors but without the company
having to pay benefits or social
security and things like that it's as a
trend you're seeing yes
so it would be a mistake to focus too
much on the gig economy or the sharing
economy as they call but there's really
nothing sharing about it without seeing
in the context of the broader economy
and so you know we're seeing the u.s. is
becoming more of a freelance nation
where more and more workers are working
as independent contractors freelancers
temp workers if you go to an auto plant
today 50% of the workers in that auto
plant are temp workers and they're
working right alongside the regularly
employed w-2 workers doing the exact
same job but they're getting half to pay
virtually no safety net no job security
if you go to a pharmaceutical company
Merck they had a plant this one plant
where they laid off 400 excuse me they
sold the plant to another company the
new company laid off all 400 workers
then hired back the same 400 workers as
contractors and by doing this what a
company does is they save about 30
percent on their labor costs because
you're not paying for health care Social
Security Medicare you're not even paying
for injured worker compensation so a lot
of these workers an uber driver gets
injured on the job
there's no uninjured injured worker
compensation to help that worker they
have to pay for their own medical bills
and if they lose wages because they're
out of work because they're injured they
have to pay out of their own savings so
there's nothing for these workers you're
basically on your own
they like to call it the you know you're
the CEO of your own business if you're
in the gig economy but really it's sort
of like the on your own Society you're
on your own and there's no safety net
beneath you so this is it's happening
the gig economy it's happening in the
traditional economy more and more Steven
Hill is our guest and talking about the
themes laid out in his book raw deal
taking a look at what's known as
independent contractors how they're
affected by these new companies and the
larger economy if you want to ask in
questions 202 7 for 80,000 won for
Republicans 202 some four eight eight
thousand for Democrats and for
independence 202 some four eight eight
thousand two also if you're an
independent contractor and you want to
give your story and talk about your
experience you can give us a call at 202
seven four eight eight thousand three
you call these folks 1099 workers right
1099 workers refers to the IRS form that
these workers receive as is instead of a
w-2 form that most regular employed
workers received
and this is happening across occupations
industries so even sir for example in
the universities today there's a lot of
faculty hire that are called adjunct
faculty that's just a fancy term for a
temp worker
they're basically a someone who's hired
to lecture a class for that class only
and they don't know if they have a job
the next semester or the semester after
that it's just happening in many many
occupations industries or more and more
workers are being hired in this way and
this the safety net was set up for the
type of worker who had a single employer
worked full-time for that employer and
that workplace became kind of a mini New
Deal site that's what you got your
health care your retirement your you
know all the other safety net components
and as more and more workers aren't
working that way anymore they're not
covered by the labor laws in the same
way and so our labor laws really need to
be updated and modernized to account for
the new ways that are the work force is
working here's our first call for you
it is from Gary Connersville Indiana
Democrats line you're on with Stephen
Hill go ahead first of all I say I thank
God for people like you is out there
telling the real truth about what's
going on out there in terms of our
economic status and let me just say that
the will of the people when it comes to
the porter and what's left of the middle
class means nothing to these elitist and
that's kind of what they were something
to put a previous guest and I I'm damn
mad I really am and there's no respect
for Humanity at all it's all about
capitalism that's what it's all about
and they look at you like a piece of
garbage like you're letting their shoes
and you're just expendable and you're
just met unless you can become one of us
you're meaningless let me ask you this
or are you a Bernie Sanders supporter
I'm you know I haven't endorsed any
candidates I sort of come at it from
more of an independent analyst position
and so I don't haven't endorsed any
candidate I see Bernie's scene is
raising some important issues which i
think is is good particularly expanding
Social Security I think this is
something that if we're going to make
the safety net work
for the types of workers who have now
multiple employers and you know
sometimes some of these workers go from
job to job they might have one job for
two hours another one for two days
another one for two weeks and they got
to keep constantly finding the next job
so we have to have a safety net that
supports these workers between jobs and
having something like an expanded social
security would be better than a 401k
system because with a 401k system as
we've seen after a few decades of
experience that if you don't have if
you're not saving enough money you can't
invest in your 401k it's just that
simple
so being able to pay into the Social
Security system and getting more from
that Social Security I think is the way
we have to rejigger our retirement
system in order to make it work I
actually have a book out about that just
this month called expects panned Social
Security now it's Republican line this
is from Houston Texas Mike you're on
with our guest good morning
Big Joe Stephen even you said that you
don't trust or imply that you don't
trust tobacco companies
but I wondered you trust the VA you care
for to care for military patients or do
you think that they're do you think that
note the VA will fire rogue employees or
do you think it's okay that the VA has
two sets of books for their schedules so
that they can they can deceive their
patients also I think that the
capitalist system is the most honest
most brutal way that an economy can be
run it is and people can expect as long
as government doesn't interfere and in
truth less than right you raise more
poor out of their destitute conditions
across the globe than in any other
system look at North Korea look at
Venezuela I mean I mentioned this other
kind of health care or social security
net where's that money coming from you
get a print it okay well actually my
other book that just came out expands
Social Security now I talked about how
we can pay for it but that's a longer
conversation I'm in terms of your your
your point about capitalism I would
agree with you that capitalism is the
greatest wealth generator that humans
have ever devised but there's a question
there who gets that wealth whose pockets
does it flow into and if you look around
the globe you can actually see that
there's
different types of capitalism today I we
have in the US what I call Wall Street /
Silicon Valley capitalism in places like
Germany I was just in Berlin for five
months they have what I call social
capitalism so they take the capitalist
engine that is generating all this
wealth and they they put the the wealth
into different institutions that create
a more broadly shared prosperity of
things like healthcare retirement
childcare and all these sorts of things
so I don't think it's just capitalism or
nothing it's there's different types of
capitalism and I think we have to really
think about how do we adjust our
capitalism especially with these new
digital technologies that are coming
online and I have the you know the if
you listen to a lot of the experts there
saying this could replace a lot of jobs
we might not have enough jobs for humans
if this goes too far in the trajectory
that it's going and if that's the case
we have to ask some really fundamental
questions about what's important about
our capitalist economy line for
independent contractors Baltimore
Maryland Jerry hello what kind of work
do you do I used to work for IBM Global
Services got outsourced thanks to George
Bush crashing the original telecom
market then during the war he made it so
IT people could only work if you had a
top-secret security clearance but it had
to be paid for by a company since they
were outsourcing they didn't pay for
them anymore and you had to get a
contract job with one so rather than be
unemployed for the last 16 years I did
like fellow IBM employees in 2000 hung
out my own shingle I work for now these
computer markets like field nation that
tax you 13% on all the money that you
make even if you're claiming for
expenses plus Social Security Medicaid
so basically 45 to 50
cents out of every dollar that I make
that I only make when I'm on site no
time for doing the paperwork no time for
travel I think we lost them well the
caller is a good example of what's
happening to the economy where people
had regularly employed full-time jobs
and now they're becoming freelancers and
contractors there's actually a company
out of Silicon Valley called up work
it's amazing what up work can do with
the technology they have 250 regular
employees those employees use technology
to oversee 10 million freelancers all
around the world and these are
freelancers doing things like architects
engineers translation computer
programming graphic design a huge number
of occupations industries are on this
platform but what you see is that you'll
have a worker like this in the United
States saying oh I'd like to make 60 70
dollars for this job and there's someone
from the European Union saying I'd like
to make 60 70 euros and then there's
someone from the Philippines Thailand
India saying I'll take 2 dollars an hour
for the same job and these are very
trained people they have access to
technology they can finish the product
send it to you by the internet or
Dropbox or whatever so you know for
someone who's hiring someone you you
don't you know the incentive is to hire
the cheapest you can as long as you're
getting good work but the problem is
that you can go on that platform and you
can watch these workers bidding on these
jobs and the look the bids go lower and
lower and lower it's an auction it's an
online auction which the lowest bid
often wins it becomes a race to the
bottom so as more and more the workforce
works this way this is the real problem
that economy can always tolerate a
certain amount of this type of work but
what these new apps and new digital
technologies has made it easier to do is
for employers to hire and fire employers
today they're saying they want to work
for us they can turn on and off like a
garden hose well where's where does that
leave the worker that's the real
challenge that we're facing and I do you
know have solutions about what we can do
about this but in the meantime the laws
are stuck in this old way of doing
things and it's just not helping workers
very much right in the book that the
Department of Labor reports that the
nation has more temp workers than ever
before approximately 2.8 billion
representing two percent of total jobs
for temp workers and then you have the
freelancers and contractors and then the
other component of it is now the
regularly employed part-time workers so
a lot of these workers if you a
part-time they would say okay here's
your schedule for the next month that's
how it used to work now they use
technology to do what's called
just-in-time scheduling and they say
I'll let you know tomorrow if I need you
the next day or if I need you the day
after that some workers show up for work
and they say you know we don't really
need you today so just go home so
basically those workers are also
basically on-call there they're not that
different from gig economy workers at
that point so it'd be a mistake to just
simply say well the gig economy over
here
it's not that big which is what some of
the you know experts that count these
things are saying though I think it part
of it is methodological they're not
counting the right way we're not sure
how to count these sorts of workers but
beyond that you also have regularly
employed part-time workers whose
conditions are more and more like these
workers over here and so when you put
all these types of workers together
there are millions of Americans now that
are working this way and then and the
the growth and the labor force is in
this type of work not the old type of
good full-time single employer type jobs
and dependent line ultimately Altamonte
Springs Florida bill is up next mister
hello good morning
I was curious too just trying to wonder
harkening back more to the beginning of
this segment who is is supposed to
intervene in the compensation and
employment agreement between a willing
competent American adult and an employer
and why the other thing is I'm just
wondering how many more laws must change
before we actually get away from the gig
economy that you apparently disliked
Thanks
well I mean so for a lot of these
workers what typically happens is they
start out thinking you know I'm gonna
try this job I like it it has some
flexibility and so that's kind of nice
and so you know they're an adult they're
making their decision about what type of
work to do but what we typically are
finding is that after they've been
working at these
types of jobs for six months eight
months that suddenly the flexibility in
your schedule isn't as important as
having some sort of stable job and
having regular income coming in because
a lot of the workers who are working in
these sorts of jobs whether it's gig
economy or traditional economy part-time
some of them are working they're working
many jobs and they're juggling a lot
they're hustling from place to place
they're always trying to find the next
job because you don't you know the one
you have isn't gonna last very long and
so for these sorts of workers it's
almost like returning to the pre New
Deal era in the 19th century where was
just peace work that's really all it's
about I mean it's sort of as if you know
like I don't know use a sports metaphor
Tom Brady the football quarterback for
the Patriots if he only got paid when he
threw a touchdown pass he doesn't get
paid for the rest of the game he doesn't
get paid for training he doesn't get
paid for going to meetings you only get
paid when you trust you you do the
touchdown pass or if you're a chef you
only get paid by the meal you don't get
paid for the whole night or you know for
the for vacation or any sorts of things
this is what more and more the workforce
is returning to so yeah they're adults
they are making the decision to work
this way but the reality is is that a
lot of the jobs in the economy aren't
very good anymore and so they don't have
a whole lot of choice viewer off of
Twitter says why should we force all
companies to offer full benefits to all
why not have a range of companies and
let the worker decide yeah that would be
the type of thing that if we could get
to that from a regulatory standpoint
that would be a good thing to do I mean
so here's here's one thing we can do
that I talked about in the book in
chapter 10 of the of raw deal we could
create a portable safety net for example
for these workers where every business
that hires a worker regardless when that
worker is regularly employed w2 or as a
freelancer contractor temp wouldn't
matter you that business would pay a
certain amount above the wage into an
individual security account that's been
set up for that worker and that what the
amount they pay will be prorated to the
number of hours that that worker is
working for that company so if that
worker is working ten hours a week for
that company then that business would
put about you know a quarter of what a
full-time safety net would be
for a worker into that individual
security account and network it would
just use that money to purchase existing
safety net infrastructure some it would
go to health care you know to an
insurance company that has health care
some would go into the Social Security
and to Medicare into injured worker
unemployment compensation and and I
actually have modeled this using Bureau
of Labor Statistics numbers and it's not
that expensive for about two dollars and
fifty cents more above the wage for
service sector workers we could give
them a safety net that would even
include five days of paid sick leave you
know we have forty million
private-sector workers in the United
States that have no paid sick leave so
they're showing up to work sick
infecting all their co-workers what kind
of sense does that make so there I think
we could regulate this in a way that
would allow the some of the good of this
these new ways of work and come forward
you know the flexibility and what have
you but not leave these workers
basically stranded on their own with
with no safety net no help whatsoever
you know in a kind of on your own
society even though joining us the
author of raw deal how the uber economy
and runaway capitalism are screwing
American workers also a senior fellow at
the New America Foundation San Diego
California Democrats line Jason up next
hi hi I'm Owen yes you're on glad yeah
yes I didn't noticing some type of trend
that with the defense contractors they
claim that they want to hire independent
contractor workers but they claim that
old we can't blame them here in the US
so what they're doing they're getting
these contractors from foreign countries
paying it right here paying housing and
get them here and they're getting the
jobs where the qualified contractors
here in the u.s. they're their thing to
be looking over them there's something
about playing all the main they're
cheaper work and you know and it's no
easy for them to get a security
clearance and most sense of the fact
because for American workers the only
thing you look at as far as its security
clearance is on your credit yeah I mean
there's a lot of practices that we've
been using
the us that when they happened at low
enough numbers they were okay you know
they didn't hurt the broader macro
economy but now more and more workers
are as more and more workers work this
way
as you know corporations are more
profitable now than they've ever been in
history and they they're leaving a lot
of that they're sending that money
offshore so that they don't have to pay
taxes on it so they're not investing in
new plants and new companies here in the
US so they're they are hiring more
workers from abroad whether it's through
a company like up work using the gig
economy or just bringing workers here
from abroad you know at a certain point
if this becomes too great we start
eating our own seed we have to be
careful that because we are a capitalist
economy 70% of the economy is driven by
consumer spending well if not enough
people have enough money in their
pockets and their bank accounts to buy
up the goods and services that are being
produced by the companies at that point
companies start they don't need as many
workers they start laying off those
workers we have fewer customers they
have fewer consumers and we get into
this downward cycle that becomes
deflationary and and recessionary in its
nature this is I think in some ways
explains what's happening to our economy
today is we already are seeing the
impacts of this type of economy where
not enough people have enough wealth get
enough income to buy up the goods and
services the company is saying I don't
see the customers out there to you know
to pay for if I were to ramp up
production and create more jobs and so I
mean sort of there's a sort of a famous
story goes back a few decades where
henry ford ii was giving a tour to his
new plant with all the robots that were
automating i was being put into that
plant to Walter Reuther the head of the
United Auto Workers and he says Walter
how are you gonna get union dues out of
those robots and Walter sets them Henry
how're you going to get them to buy your
cars this is the dilemma that we are
facing in our in our economy in a major
way and we have to really have a more
sophisticated conversation about it
then I think we're seeing in the current
presidential campaign or and just simply
saying well I talked to my uber driver
and he he says he likes it just fine so
I think it must be okay
as far as the candidates themselves any
addressing squarely this issue or at
least how to fix the problems as you see
them they they aren't really talking
about this issue they they are talking
about the economy isn't doing well we
have to you know make it better but I
see them pretty light on details in
terms of what exactly we're going to do
how do we gonna make corporations bring
those profits home and and start
reinvesting in America how are we going
to boost infrastructure which would
create jobs how are we going to regulate
this sharing economy gig economy so that
these workers have a safety net these
are the real questions that we're going
to be facing more and more president
obama recently did speak out in favor of
creating a portable safety net which is
what i proposed in my book chapter in
chapter 10 of my book and in a
standalone paper as well so I think
these are the directions that more and
more people are starting to think about
but we're only at the very beginning of
this conversation are these type of
companies growing in nature these
sharing economy types of companies they
the Silicon Valley type company is
growing quite rapidly you know some of
these companies it's true that three out
of four these startups fail nine out of
the ten of them don't make any money the
ones that do make it then become an
example for the next generation and so I
mean we've seen this sort of change in
how corporations are structured I mean
in post-world War two ERA you know you
had the big vertical companies where
everything happened under the single
roof the production of design marketing
manufacturing all under one roof then in
1980s you had Nike and Apple came along
and they sent production to low-wage
countries but still kept design and
marketing everything under the roof well
these new companies they're basically
not that much more than an app and a
website they don't have that many
employees they're not creating that many
jobs
uber has created a thousand regular jobs
for uber and then you know hundreds of
thousands of part-time jobs all over the
world that are you know people come and
go too because it's a transient sort of
temporary job you know even Facebook for
example only has about 12,000 employees
you compare that to the auto companies
or to IBM they hire hundreds of
of people so if if if you have to
realize that these Silicon Valley
companies are not creating that many
jobs and they're using technology and
algorithms to basically hire fewer and
fewer people and do it all through
automation that's that's the chat that's
the trend going forward here's key from
Palm Bay Florida Republican line good
morning sir mr. ail can you hear me yes
I can yeah just north of you in New York
City for about four thousand years
people have gathered on a certain Street
there and they trade millions of dollars
worth of goods on a handshake because
they're honest and trust each other and
morals and values it's called a diamond
trade for thousands of years on a
handshake you know the difference with
our economy is we got to have contracts
and governments we're gonna make them
put a safety net we're going to make
them do this and because of law holics
they get these laws into place and then
the other lawyers that aren't and
government figure a way around these
things so then we gotta fix it again and
fix it again if we taught more
principles and values and morals our
economy would be a lot better and with
all these laws a contract these days you
could have a hundred page contract and
get out of it because we don't have
morals and values anymore
it's turning into an oligarchy well it's
a fair point we can certainly have too
much regulation it doesn't tend to
create jobs for lawyers that's you know
they've talked about creating a new
category of workers called dependent
contractor and which you know if we
could do it would probably be a good
idea but it does create have a tendency
to create more rules that then the
lawyers find the loopholes around and
that's why the proposal that I've made
for a portable safety net plan it would
apply to every business regardless of
whether that that however that that
worker is working whether a freelancer
contractor or regularly employed and by
doing it this way we get around all
these loopholes because that way we know
everybody is covered because right now
the way it works if I'm an employer
and you're an employer Pedro and I'm
hiring contractors and freelancers and
I'm saving 30% of my labor costs because
I'm not paying for things like health
care Social Security Medicare injured
worker compensation and you are that's
going to hurt you your price is gonna
have to be higher than me so that puts
pressure on you and then we're seeing
this this downward race to the bottom as
more and more employers are feeling
these sorts of pressures so by doing
this portable safety net we take away
that incentive to going to this type of
freelancers Society model because you're
not going to save 30% on your labor
costs anymore there might still be a
reason to hire freelancers and
contractors there are legitimate reasons
for labor flexibility for companies but
it wouldn't be because you're just gonna
basically not have to pay for any things
for your workers I mean it's so that we
have in a math society capitalist
economy like this we have to recognize
that there's always gonna be winners and
losers and so what do you do to the
people who aren't doing as well as the
people who are doing extremely well you
just say no you're on your own well
that's what feudalism was like I think
we've come a few centuries since that
we're trying to figure out how do we
make this capitalist economy work in a
way that creates a broadly shared
prosperity that to me is what what we've
been doing in the post-world War two ERA
decade after decade sometimes we change
things to make it work better and and so
this is what we're doing again it's just
the latest turn of the wheel there's new
technology we have to figure out how to
integrate these technologies into our
economy so that they work for everybody
instead of just for a handful an
independent contractor from London
England on the line
Simon go ahead good morning how are you
yeah well basically all I'm going to say
and I think is really important because
let's get a neutral perspective here now
as you will have all known in America
all these some of you will have known
Britain voted outside the United sort of
a united European Union basic brexit
happened now one of the reasons why that
happens and it revolves around the
subject matter that you're talking is
down to the fact that a lot of
businesses were to undercut British
workers would go into countries like
Hungary and Romania where you have with
people's minimum way
would be like 1 euro 50 that's about $1
40 per hour hoeing massive gangs of
people from Eastern Europe and because
of the way the European Union works they
were able to undercut local wages in
Western Europe where the economies are
richer by moving people from east to
west but at the same rate of pay that
they would pay in the east
now that is meant that in Britain lots
of people are coming over they've been
able to earn a lot of they've been
basically paid the same wage they would
back in their home country miss endicott
workers now exactly the same thing is
happening in the United States but you
don't quit because these people in
Europe are legal workers this is a
difference in the United States they're
illegal workers now what you need to do
to resolve this situation and this is
what President Obama tried to do is make
all these workers legal stop the press
gangs the chain gangs essentially of
mass illegal workers by giving them
legal status that way American workers
and contractors will not be undercut
because of the fact that they will be in
a much stronger position to turn around
to their gang masters and say no I am
NOT going to get paid a rubbish wait for
the hard jobs that I do
salmon's I thank you for the call sign
we appreciate it well let our guest
respond well the caller is making a very
good point about as the as the workforce
becomes more global and as this kind of
gig economy app technology makes it
easier for a business to hire a worker
not only in Romanian in terms of fear if
you're in the European Union but you can
hire them from India from Thailand the
Philippines and you know these are
countries now that also have workers
that are very skilled and you know it's
really for these workers in those
countries it's it's a good thing they're
able to get work but for the workers
here it's it's actually creates quite a
few challenges and so that's where we
have to really think about I mean we
want China India Brazil to come up in
the world
you know the idea of China as a failed
state is too terrible to even come
plate so we have to sort of figure out
how do we grow the global economy how do
we make its American workers can do well
and that other workers and other
countries can do well here in the US I
think when you look at other countries
that have things like portable safety
nets they work extremely well I was just
in Berlin for five months and you can
see how the system there works where a
lot of the workers that are working
freelance they have a safety net there's
an and with European Union law if you're
a temporary worker or a regular employee
part-time worker employers can't
discriminate you in terms of labor
conditions and making sure you're
covered by things by healthcare and that
kind of thing the way we can here in the
United States so I think this is it's a
matter of upgrading modernizing our
labor laws so that the workers who these
workers who are working from multiple
businesses now working you know two
hours here two days two weeks there and
putting stitching their financial lives
together from lots of different jobs
there they aren't going to be at a
disadvantage in terms of building and
being able to build a good life for
themselves where when they get to the
end of their retired years they have a
decent retirement they have a decent
life this is what I think we have to go
to so the caller's example because of
brexit that does that mean independent
Contras they're contractors in the u k--
and britain now don't have those
protections now and basically they could
be affected then the protections they
had under the EU well well you know the
UK is gonna have to renegotiate its
whole relationship with with Europe so
it's hard to know how those sorts of
situations are going to work out I mean
I they call her you know it was I
appreciate that for a lot of UK workers
they felt that they were being injured
by this but for the workers in Romania
and Poland in other places it was
helpful to them so if you're trying to
grow the overall European economy you
have this rich nation poorer nations
split where the richer nation has to be
willing to help out the poor nations
here in the US we have a federal system
where you know a state like New York
California Illinois they send more in
taxes to Washington DC than they get
back and then those funds are given to
states like Mississippi Alabama Alaska
and others that receive more in
federal taxes and they pay out so that's
how a federal system a transfer union
works and that's what you know the
European Union is into a process of
figuring out how United do we want to be
as a continent that process takes
decades so you can't judge things by the
momentary headlines that we're seeing
you think about the United States like
young America in 1790s we had very
similar tensions and conflicts going on
and in fact we fought a civil war
seventy years after our nation's
founding over not only just slavery but
states rights versus central government
can a central government tell a state
that they can't have slavery that's what
the civil war was over and we fought
that seventy years after our nation's
founding so European Union is and I
think in some ways is going to work out
fine but it's going to take time to work
all these tensions and conflicts out
Clyde for Minnesota Democrats line
you're next this might be a perfect
segue to my thought I'd like to use the
metaphor of planting a garden and I
would also like to say we learn by three
example we learned by example necessary
inference and direct command when we're
born into this capitalistic system long
before we go to elementary school we
look around us and we see what our
parents do our little playmates do and
as we grow things become more
sophisticated but we always never seem
to put people first and let's go back to
the beginning of the founding fathers we
capitalized on slave labor we
capitalized on what the Indians taught
us how to survive we used them and then
we enslaved them and this system has
come forward so we have spawned one
generation after another of capitalism
what the market will bear but not what
people can bear if you study to
investigative reporters during the 80s
during the Reagan administration Barlett
and steel from the National Inquirer
they showed what Congress could do they
passed laws and a lot of loopholes in
the laws for hostile takeovers for
companies to raid other companies that
were smaller but we're very solvent take
their medical benefits and their pension
funds and leave these people hanging out
to dry okay : thank you
well the callers making I think some
very good points about I think what I
took from it was how he
structured corporations and and what
corporations are allowed to do these big
wealthy entities that have such a key
role in our economy one of the other
things that I proposed in my book raw
deal is something called
co-determination
and as I mention I was just in Berlin
for five months and studying I've
studied the German system quite quite
thoroughly and what they have there is
incense they've redesigned the
corporation so you have big companies
like BMW and Daimler and Siemens but
they're different than US corporations
because by law the workers that work for
those businesses get to elect 50 percent
of the members of the boards of
directors of that of that corporation it
would be as if here in the United States
by law Walmart Walmart had to allow its
workers who had 50 percent of the
members of the board of directors of
Walmart that's the impact of that what
they have done in German they use this
in Sweden an economy is doing extremely
well Germany is doing well many places
in in Europe are using this type of
co-determination work or elected boards
of directors so if we and and it doesn't
take away the control of the company
from the business in the CEO but what it
creates is a culture of consultation you
have to as a CEO you have to be in touch
with your employees you have to inquire
about their viewpoints and certain
things and it does give the employees a
certain amount of input into decisions
about the future direction of the
company and how that company is going to
act you know Germany is like one of the
largest exporters in the world it's
worked very successful they have a lot
of fortune 500 companies it has not
undermined their competitiveness which
some would argue is why you wouldn't
want to do something like this it's
working quite well there and so these
are the types of things that we could be
doing here in the United States as well
that I think would help us to make sure
that the economy is gonna be structured
in a way that it works for it preserves
the safety net preserves the the social
contract that we had that made us at the
envy of the world we were the most
prosperous country in the world and in
many ways we're not anymore and and
these are the types of things that I
think will get us back thoughts of our
guest Stephen Hill available in the book
raw deal how the uber economy and
runaway capitalism are screwing American
war
curse thanks for your time thanks page
it's a great pleasure thanks